Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Una spiaggia mozzafiato;
delle palme in lontananza;
un mare azzurro; un'acqua cristallina.
Ero in viaggio ormai da settimane,
un viaggio di esplorazione:
mistico, per certi versi.
Avevo già percorso migliaia di chilometri
con un vecchio maggiolone
sgangherato del '65.
Improvvisamente, e nuotando
a pochi metri dalla riva,
mi trovo davanti a lei:
una tartaruga marina.
Wow.
Nella mia testa, nel mio cuore, un clic.
Ero in Messico da cinque mesi,
e sarei tornato poco dopo in Spagna.
Quell'evento ha cambiato la mia vita.
E mi sono detto: voglio proteggere
questo ambiente meraviglioso.
Questa tartaruga mi sta chiedendo aiuto.
E da quel momento,
è cominciato il mio viaggio
verso l'economia circolare,
personale e professionale.
Era il 2009, 12 anni fa.
Oggi l'economia circolare
è un'espressione di moda.
Rappresenta un modo
di produzione, e di consumo,
verso lo scarto zero.
Interessante, vero?
Necessario, forse.
Scopriamolo insieme.
E più che che su una spiaggia paradisiaca,
credo che siamo più
in una situazione di questo tipo,
in una barca in balia delle onde.
E quindi, probabilmente,
per cercare di capire come andare avanti
il passo che potremmo cercare di fare
è andare un passo indietro.
Per capire prima a cosa serve l'economia,
e poi costruire insieme una
che sia allineata con i tempi che corrono.
E quindi, da dove viene
la parola economia?
Chi mi aiuta con il greco?
Qualcuno?
Oiko-nomos, grazie.
E cosa significa?
Significa la gestione
di quello che abbiamo a casa.
Quale casa?
Questa: il pianeta
in cui siamo, in cui viviamo.
E cosa ci facciamo,
con quello che abbiamo a casa?
Lo usiamo per soddisfare
le nostre necessità.
Uno dei modelli più conosciuti
è la piramide delle necessità,
sui quali scalini
troviamo i bisogni umani:
dalla base, in cui troviamo
i bisogni fisiologici,
quindi mangiare, dormire, bere -
acqua, non fate i furbi.
Se andiamo su, invece,
troviamo quelli che hanno
la relazione con gli altri,
quindi l'amicizia,
il senso di appartenenza;
se invece andiamo
verso la punta, il top del top,
troviamo il senso di autorealizzazione,
quello che dà senso alle nostre vite.
Se ci pensate,
più andiamo su più queste necessità
diventano intangibili, effimere,
molto influenzate dai capricci
della nostra cultura
e della nostra società.
E se io vi chiedessi: ma voi siete felici?
Vi sentite realizzati?
E questo sì che è preoccupante,
altro che il greco.
Io ho già la risposta.
Probabilmente, direste:
"Sì, insomma dai. Si tira avanti",
perché qua in Veneto dire
"Sì, felicissimo! " uno -
ti guardano anche male, no?
Cosa prende a questo buontempone?
E la questione è che,
indipendentemente dal fatto
di essere veneti o no,
quello che noi misuriamo
nella realizzazione personale
è la distanza tra quello
che io ho, o penso di avere,
e quello che penso che dovrei raggiungere.
E questa situazione, questa tensione,
questa ansia continua che abbiamo
ha a che fare con due
grandi nemici che abbiamo.
Il primo in noi stessi,
perché abbiamo questa tendenza innata
a desiderare quello
che non abbiamo ancora;
il secondo nemico è legato
al modello produttivo attuale,
che si chiama "economia lineare".
E questo modello soddisfa
le nostre necessità basiche,
quelle che sono alla base della piramide;
ma si prodiga, anche,
di generarne di fittizie.
Direte: come necessità fittizie?
Sì, è un modello a senso unico
basato nell'estrazione
aggressiva delle risorse
per trasformarli in milioni,
anzi miliardi di prodotti e servizi;
e un uso, un consumo spensierato
caratterizzato dalla fase di usa e getta.
Questo modello, come potete immaginare,
genera delle problematiche;
e alla fine,
quando io ho più di quello
di cui ho bisogno per vivere,
cos'è che succede?
Che per poter assorbire
questa economia di scala,
questa produzione di miliardi di prodotti,
devo associare inevitabilmente
il successo nella vita
con quello che sono i beni materiali:
più abbiamo nella società, e più siamo.
E quindi, quando noi passiamo
a un modello di questo tipo,
come possiamo immaginare,
gli effetti in un pianeta finito
sono evidenti ogni giorno.
Infatti, cosa direbbero i greci
rispetto a quella che è
la gestione corretta delle risorse?
La degradazione ambientale
che noi stiamo vivendo,
il riscaldamento globale,
la crisi dell'energia o delle forniture
sono dei segnali che ci dicono
che il sistema non sta funzionando.
E se guardiamo al futuro,
capiamo anche che ci sarà
un aumento demografico,
ma avremo anche un aumento
della classe media emergente.
Tutto questo, ovviamente,
aumenterà la sfida che abbiamo davanti.
Ma allora, la domanda che mi faccio è:
ma se parliamo di classe media,
di chi stiamo parlando?
Di che economia stiamo parlando?
Come se tutti stessimo rincorrendo
le stesse necessità.
In realtà, il mondo è diviso
in tre grandi gruppi:
il 45 percento della popolazione mondiale
non sa esattamente
dove troverà acqua e cibo oggi;
il 35 percento è la cosiddetta
classe media emergente,
che sta passando
dalla bicicletta al motorino.
Dall'appartamento modello tugurio,
con umidità inclusa,
alla villetta a schiera con giardino.
Pensate che, addirittura,
vanno anche in vacanza.
E poi c'è un 20 percento.
Lì siamo noi.
Noi possediamo l'80%
della ricchezza del mondo.
Noi abbiamo così tanto,
che dobbiamo addirittura farsi aiutare
da dei consulenti di minimalismo.
Ce n'è una, specialmente famosa,
è giapponese, non so se la conoscete.
Scrive dei libri, ha una serie -
vedo dei sorrisini,
no perché avete le mascherine,
ma dei sorrisi di complicità
sotto le mascherine.
E questa è meravigliosa
perché tu la assumi, la paghi anche -
ovviamente, è una consulente -
va a casa tua e ti aiuta a essere felice
buttando via quel'accumulo di accozzaglia
che hai a casa tua,
e che hai comprato nella falsa speranza
che ti migliorasse la vita.
Quindi, la questione è:
dobbiamo forse ridisegnare un'economia
affinché possiamo soddisfare le necessità
di tutte queste persone -
quelle biologiche, ma anche
quelle aspirazionali diciamo -
in una maniera radicalmente differente.
Proviamo a farlo insieme.
E per farlo, quello che faremo
sarà lavorare sulla piramide.
Lo faremo nei livelli inferiori,
quelli più terra terra;
quello sopra, quello più aspirazionale,
lo lasciamo alla fine,
così vi lascio con un po' di suspence.
La questione è questa:
noi siamo l'unica specie nel pianeta
che distrugge l'ambiente in cui vive.
Cioè, non è un bel curriculum:
è più una fedina penale
la nostra in realtà, vero?
Se noi prendiamo
una società molto numerosa,
per esempio come le formiche,
loro vivono qua da milioni di anni
e non stanno mai ferme, vero?
Sono peggio dei veneti, quasi.
E corrisponderebbero
a 30 miliardi di persone.
Eppure contribuiscono
alla vita sulla Terra,
su cui noi, in 200 anni,
abbiamo tolto gli equilibri della Terra,
abbiamo creato dei problemi
rispetto a queste formiche
che da milioni vivono
in simbiosi con la natura,
con l'ambiente circostante.
Quindi la mia domanda è:
e se chiedessimo aiuto alla natura?
Se avessimo l'umiltà di imparare
da chi è sempre stato qua,
e con grande successo?
La perfezione matematica,
simboleggiata dalla costante aurea,
è attorno a noi,
e combina funzionalità con estetica.
La perfezione esiste,
se avessimo il coraggio
di poterla apprezzare.
In natura, tutto è alimento
di qualcos'altro.
Lo spreco ridiventa risorsa.
Avviene una redenzione.
L'economia circolare, come è ovvio,
si ispira a questa natura:
è un modello rigenerativo
che pretende di arrivare
a una reincarnazione dello spreco
verso nuove forme di vita funzionali
agli ecosistemi naturali,
ambientali ed economici.
Si tratta di un modello
in cui noi dobbiamo progettare,
con la circolarità in mente,
prodotti, servizi e business.
Dobbiamo sviluppare,
e possiamo sviluppare,
modelli produttivi a chilometro zero,
dove possiamo ricollegarci
con la domanda reale
che hanno i consumatori:
produrre dove, quando, quanto
e soprattutto se ne abbiamo bisogno.
Un modello in cui possiamo, quindi,
svincolare le necessità fittizie
che il sistema ha dovuto creare -
è come se andassimo in bicicletta:
l'economia lineare non si può fermare,
perché dipende dall'assorbimento
di questi prodotti
che noi stiamo commercializzando.
E quindi,
se noi riuscissimo ad allineare
gli interessi economici,
la forma di monetizzazione delle aziende,
cioè la forma di far schèi, come si dice,
con quelli che sono
gli interessi del bene comune,
probabilmente potremmo andare avanti.
E le soluzioni le abbiamo,
le tecnologie le abbiamo:
quello che dobbiamo fare
è aggiungere una consapevolezza
rispetto a quello che è
la nostra vita sulla Terra,
e soprattutto cominciare a considerare
i diversi valori sociali
che ci possono permettere di andare
verso una concezione del successo
diversa nella vita.
E questo modello rigenerativo, quindi -
e con questo mi ricollego
con quello che è la piramide:
abbiamo visto che sopra vi avevo lasciato
in sospeso con la piramide.
L'economia lineare,
questa economia a senso unico,
è una fabbrica di desideri insoddisfatti
e di necessità fittizie.
E come dicevano le antiche filosofie,
e anche il buon senso,
quello ci può portare
solo alla frustrazione,
e all'infelicità cronica.
Non avremo mai abbastanza:
mancherà sempre qualcosa
in quella vita perfetta,
quella vita da pubblicità
a cui noi aspiriamo.
In realtà, il problema è che la vita
è già perfetta com'è:
bisognerebbe apprezzarla,
e cominciare a viverla davvero.
E pensate che abbiamo addirittura
linearizzato le nostre relazioni umane:
usa e getta, anche là.
E quindi, quello che vi propongo
è un cambio relazionale.
Questo modello rigenerativo
è un cambio relazionale
tra quello che è la nostra
relazione con l'ambiente -
quindi cambiare da un modello aggressivo,
di estrazione delle risorse,
a un modello di collaborazione
e apprendimento della natura -
e con gli altri:
la pandemia ce l'ha dimostrato,
le persone che ci sono
vicine, i nostri cari,
sono quelli che danno senso
alla nostra vita
e con noi stessi:
staccarsi dalla "ruota del criceto"
su cui stiamo pedalando -
non ho trovato il termine tecnico
di quello su cui il criceto corre,
e quindi noi siamo vittime e carnefici
di questa situazione.
Quindi dovremmo riabbracciare noi stessi,
essere in grado di accettare
che lo sviluppo umano va
verso un'altra direzione
rispetto a quella che questo
sistema lineare ci vuole convincere.
E quindi vi chiedo, o vi ricordo:
siamo partiti con una barca,
vi ricordate che era in balia delle onde?
Non era una buona situazione:
eppure, dobbiamo riprendere
in mano il timone.
Perché dobbiamo continuare a navigare.
Alla fine, come diceva André Gide,
finché non avremo il coraggio
di navigare durante un tempo,
lasciando la spiaggia,
quindi il nostro porto sicuro,
perdendo la vista del porto
sicuro, durante un tempo,
non troveremo mai nuovi territori,
nuove opportunità o nuove speranze.
Quindi, buona navigazione.
E vi auguro di trovare, anche voi,
la vostra tartaruga.
Grazie.
(Applausi)